salut ! Aujourd'hui on est lundi
a partir d'aujourd'hui je vous mettrais tous les lundis un vlog, sur ma chaine, sur quelque chose que j'aurai fait d'intéressant
vous voyez cette vidéo lundi, je l'ai enregistrée il y a 2 jours
samedi, là je m'apprête à partir à roy mal maison
où sont enregistrés les championnats de France de magie !
cette année on m'a demandé de faire partie du jury
donc je vais faire partie du jury des championnats de France là cette année
ça se deroule ce soir, je sais pas trop comment ça se deroule
j'ai été déjà jury sur des concours de magie je sais pas trop qui sont les autres jurés
je sais juste qu'on m'a appelé en me disant prends de quoi écrire
alors je vais prendre de quoi écrire
j'espère que je vais voir des belles choses ce soir
j'espère que je vais être bluffer
aussi bien que par les tours de magie que par le rythme
que par la créativité
des candidats
et comme c'est un vlog bien sûr je vous emmène avec moi
aller venez dans ma poche
venez par là
***Décors***musique***
et dans le jury ce soir il y a aussi Caroline ! *coucou* ça va être un jury de folie
*** férix shilet ? ***quand tu te fais interviewer est-ce que je fais une interview du real ?
ba tu fais ce que tu veux
moi je suis laurent le real
mais généralement c'est plutôt moi qui interview plutôt que ce soit moi
et ben ça c'est joli
ça fait bientôt 3-4 ans mais on se connaît depuis bientôt 12-15 ans
et sur la magie ça fait 3 ans ?
sur le magie partout au monde ça fait 3 ans
en 3 ans et demies on a fait une 15éne de spectacle ensemble
pour la télévision voilà
ah ba donc c'est peut-être toi qui as fait les mandrage d'or en 2012 ?
oui, certainement
moi j'étais dans l'émission pour le coup
c'est lui qui m'a réalisé
salut
une légende raconte qu'il y a toujours des trappes sur les scène des magiciens
alors allons chercher les trappes
***décors***musique***
je peux enfin le confirmer il n'y a pas de trappes sur cette scène
là, ici
par contre peut-être qu'ils ont des scies
le public est rentré
on est en train de faire les petits plans de groupes
pour je sais pas quoi en fait
et moi je suis avec mon pote jêrome
bonjour monsieur
ça va bien ? ouais
ça tourne là ? ouais
c'est incroyable cette petite caméra !
tu te vois là
oh caroline qui est là
ça me fait une tête de cheval, ah oui ça t'allonge
ah oui on dirai un cheval. ça c'est le réalisateur
laurent real le présentateur. c'est laurent
ça fait quand même un nez incroyable
incroyable
est-ce qu'il faut que tu te recules ?
ça c'est une mise en abime
on peut créer un trou noir en faisant ça
fais attention
c'est dingue
on voit les points noirs tout ça
est ce qu'on voit les poils du nez ?
il n'a pas changé depuis les mandrag d'or
là tu vois plus rien
sisi justement
***décors***musique***
aller à toute à l'heure, on va être sérieux maintenant. parce que attention
huuue
on va être très gentil
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a des mecs derrière moi avec des caméras
et ce soir il y a caroline marx
***applaudissement***
mais ils te font un triomphe
***applaudisement***
INCROYABLE TRIOMPHE
***applaudissement***
alors que pour moi personne n'a parlé !!! RIEN
là il y a un mec qui est en train de se faire depouyer
sur scène c'est un intermet
reste plus qu'un numéro à passer
je vous conseille de regarder l'émission car c'est très très bien ce qu'on a vu
je vous dirais les...mais non je peux pas filmer les résultats, j'ai pas le droit de les annoncer
c'est ouf
c'étais vachement dur de noter en fait
mais j'ai quand même 3 gros coups de cœur
c'est tous les artistes de ce soir je vais pas faire la remise des prix mais c'étais vraiment très bien bravo
bravo à tous
le jury, je suis impressionné par la caméra
la caméra nous regarde et nous nous regardons la caméra
tu peux la regarder
je vous presente le prix coup de coeur
ah oui c'est moi
vas-y félicite
je vous présente le 2ème prix
yeah it's me
parce que apparemment j'ai le droit de diffuser enfin je sais pas trop
et on s'en fout on s'en fout
il a fait... ah non je vous dis pas ce qu'il a fait
faut venir voir le spectacle
regarder la télé sur paris première
ah oui sinon on vous dira pas
et puis il est où le premier prix ?
ba je sais pas
il se sont tous barrés
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs je vous présente luc Lachance détective privé
c'est qui le 3ème prix ?
c'est lui ! et ba c'est moi
BRAVO
merci
félicitation
j'ai pas eu le temps de te le dire de vive voix
et le premier prix est attribué à
aladin
hhaaa
bravo
quand vous allez voir ce numéro vous allez kiffer
vous allez tout de suite pourquoi il a cette grosse coupe dans les mains
ce vlog est maintenant terminé
on est lundi
aujourd'hui je vais monté la vidéo de tout ce que vous venez de voir
du coup
heuu forcément
si il se passe un truc d'intéressant dans ma semaine je vlogerrais et le posterai le lundi
tous les lundis je ferai des vlog comme ca, je suis un peu en train de revoir les formats comment va s'organiser la chaîne
également ce matin je viens de vous poser une question sur Facebook, mon profil et ma fan page
pour la vidéo de jeudi
et ça aussi je le ferai toutes les semaines comme la semaine dernière d'ailleurs
le lundi je vous pose une question et le jeudi j'en fais une vidéo
si cette vidéos vous a plu et les nouvelles idées aussi vous pouvez bien sûr laisser un... comment on dis déjà...
POUCE EN L'AIR
passez une bonne semaine et rendez-vous demain à 17h pour le prochain mental vlog
tchao !!!
***outro***